вогонь по місячній основа і знову на вулицях
різьблених міс Білорусі
то послання до уряду мінську самі роки
монстр анд і званого трохи підвалини днях
розрубати це анти цивільних законах
і так я за крима про так званий декрет
номер три обидва закон про дармо дитинства
[музика]
дармоїдам вигин нас указом їжі зрубати
не лекція плану з бресту вона не
суперечачи хіба його на юні двори до
цьому прогресу і чий артроз коли новий
закон набирає чинності манабу система
гуртувати і чималий штраф люди люди
бідні люди голодні люди бачу ці це
чоловіки травня роботи там ще дітям не
може у звітуєте обидва вати
нічим і за провожаючі у такої від дай
пекла взяті
потім вона ця машина ніж вони to paris та
про так ти че мені нирку продати їм турне
зробити вигляд держави жінка допомагають
рими та її плати ти куди так на дармоїд
схильні побачити підстав
теж разом за нашими друзями по
нещастя ось у я акцію протесту відтінки
від його доступного дня на площі будинку
виду тася мітинг миска влада раб там ви
вирішила організувати та дитину годину what a
protest увальни до
але розбившись порушує будинку скакун кому
дорогу та даних приїду та cd дали більше
учасників
близько тисячі людей причому у c не
політичні активісти вибач громадян та
і ким світла роздаємо і стив дечому
благополучніше краї не я до нас кажуть у
наших тіла ящиках стиль до хворих дітей
c нормально околиця для того ж ви
проводьте ну до школи треба брати кредит
на спаді ви нас є поліцейські на
демонстрантів у ньому майже назвав таїти
увагу задоволений і у кого на Білорусі
ще більшу на спаді вангу зграя
запрошення мером учасники мітингу на
розумова спрощення навіть адміністрації
там у ставків 3 роки наш conti бреста
домагається ваги вати
чуму на з медовими she might плід цієї
державі меру доводиться ви правда в офісі
такого в Білорусі ще не було про те, чим
можна говорити та зник на політичну
верби ху я думаю що це здоровий глузд я
думаю що справ віддаються здорових вуст
діалог можна весь для влада адже чого ти
всі налаштування горіху ват і управлінські
рішення виходять з пабу шкода пара важливу
біт 6 людей не знаю не знаю чому будемо
з поділися ще один із все-таки
почути душити йому хотілося 1 хочеться
нерви люції невинні
алла екшон їжу слухаються нічим добрим
цос правдиною закінчіть
після акції убрести куліть after за три
мало 5f молодих людей по дорозі до будинку
він його 3 мани піп я одягнений арешту
справедливо виглядаючи
inox